[Music]
remnants of a free-falling chinese
rocket that's re-entering the earth's
atmosphere
are expected to rain down on the planet
this weekend perhaps as early as
midnight tonight
eastern time that rocket is descending
from orbit in an uncontrolled re-entry
it is currently over south america
heading out toward the atlantic
space engineers won't know the exact
entry point into the earth's atmosphere
or
when until a few hours before it happens
most of the debris is expected to burn
up before that remy in ascencio
reports from hong kong
when china's long march 5b rocket
blasted off last week
the country proudly delivered the first
module of its planned space station
called harmony of the heavens but back
on earth
more headache than harmony china has
lost control of that 20-ton
rocket it's coming down on its own it
apparently is tumbling
bill harwood is cbs news space analyst
at cape canaveral florida
the rocket is passing as far north as
new york and beijing and as far south as
chile and new zealand
that means it could pretty much land
crash
really almost anywhere on the planet
that's right anywhere between 41 degrees
north latitude and 41 degrees
south latitude but what you have to
remember is the world is 75 percent
covered in water in the land area while
it's very vast
there's a lot more empty land for debris
to fall on than there are populated
areas
as sky watchers document the falling
rocket from japan to washington d.c
the white house has called for
responsible space behavior
beijing through state media has
criticized the pentagon's warnings as
western hype and not worth panicking
about
and china's foreign ministry said it's
common for upper stages
of rockets to burn up re-entering the
atmosphere
while true china's rocket has no upper
stage
the ability to restart its engine to
drive it down
and over an ocean to break apart why the
chinese don't put systems on their
rockets to
to to do the same thing we'd have to ask
them and they they're not
talking in 1979 nasa's 76-ton
skylab space station broke up dropping
debris
in western australia thankfully no one
was hurt
similarly in 2020 when china's first
long march
rocket reportedly rained wreckage over
western africa
the same way the second could do this
weekend someplace
but experts say we will all probably be
fine
for cbs this morning saturday raymie in
ascencio
hong kong this is the best part we will
all
probably probably
probably it's a good time to remember
the 70 percent
water across the globe but we're lucky
like that we
we would we might just get a visit let's
hope
you want it falling in your backyard i
don't i don't want it falling in my
backyard i'm just saying the luck of the
draw
yeah you never know you never know